the early hours of federal and
provincial elections in Nepal and a
steady trickle of Voters casting their
ballots at polling stations across
Kathmandu it's the second time Nepalese
voted under a constitution approved in
2015.
this time thousands of candidates are
taking part a significant number not
allied with major coalitions independent
candidates have been doing well it's
time to give the youth a chance anybody
can run as a candidate but because it's
a party system people have party
affiliations so the parties will win big
no party that's won elections in Nepal
has finished its five-year term due to
power struggles the incumbent prime
minister sir badur Duba has been in the
post five times his main rival KP Sharma
Oli 3 and both are running again for the
top post it's shaping up to be a
two-horse race between the ruling Nepali
Congress and the main opposition party
United Marxist leninist both have held
power in the past decade and a half or
so and are making the same old promises
the past economy is struggling to
recover after inflation reached nearly
nine percent the pandemic exposed flaws
Us in its Public Health Care system and
basic services are still inaccessible to
many in rural areas analysts say this
partly explains a surprise victory for
newcomers in local polls in May it was
unthought of that the independent voting
block would influence the proportional
representation because they would not
have the Nationwide influence but what
has happened you know the the influence
of this newcomers are on Urban space
where you have a more population these
days so while the major parties may be
assured of directly elected seats under
the proportional representation system
110 may swing to independence party we
just fielded more candidate would
definitely get more number if everything
goes well so Nepali Congress late
Coalition is likely to have more seats
but I'm I'm I still have a doubt that
there will be single-handedly able to
form the government social media and
urbanization and may have changed the
landscape of Nepalese politics but most
voters are hoping that whoever gets the
maturity will have their best interests
at heart
below Al Jazeera Kathmandu